サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチッッタパリオダパナン エタングブッダナサーサナナン
お願いします 教会の今年の初めての説法会でございます
皆様にもお釈迦様のこの人生を幸福にする宝物をね
心で覚えて持って 今年だけではなくて
ずっと幸福でいられますようにと祝願いたします
皆様方もブッダの教えを覚えているんだから
どんな悩みも苦しみも
それから毎日生きるということはいろいろトラブル続きで
あの私たちというのは幸福になることじゃなくて
毎日出てくる問題をね
なんのことなく解決することなんです
ですね バカでかい幸福っていうのはね
ちょっと妄想概念でね
そうではなくて 毎日毎日
その時その時の問題を解決して
解決して 先へ先へ進むことで
我々にはすごく充実感
よく頑張って生きているんだというね
充実感が生まれてくるんです
ですから この俗世間的に考える幸福っていうのは
人のことを見てね あの人のようになりたいとね
あの人のように成功したいと思っちゃう
これはものすごい勘違いなんですね
自分はあの人のようになりません
だから不可能なことを期待するんです
ではなくて 自分が自分で生きていることが幸福なんです
その時は毎日何かトラブルが起こるんですね
それを解決して解決していくんですね
自分の道を歩む 自分の人生を生きる
それが幸福なんです はい
以上です では 今日の話に入ります
今日はあの かなり失敗しないで幸福に生きるために必要なテーマだと思いますね
あの考えることはしてはいけないということと
いや 間違った 最初から間違って妄想してはいけないということと
考えるしかないですね
はい そういうことで思考能力をアップグレードする
グレードアップする アップグレードよりはグレードアップなんですね
ブッダの方法は何なのかと
勉強してみましょう だいたい方法っていうのはいたって簡単です
いつでも   2 3 5 分ぐらいやれば
こんなやり方だと教えてあげることできます
しかし 人間には無知があるんだからね
なかなかシンプルなことをやらないんですね
特に結果が出るものはやらないんです
結果が出ない インチキ的なものだったら元気でやっちゃうっていうのという
我々のちょっとした この何て言いますかね
問題あるんですよ だからまずそれを直さなくちゃいけない
それで仏教はすごくややこしく
この理論的なところ 真理をまず語る
真理を理解することで人々はかなり倒れますけどね
結構大変膨大ですからね
それでやってみなさい
それからシンプルな方法を教えてあげます
はい では理論に入ります
欠かせない心の活動 いわゆる心が活動することは欠かせないんです
はい 第1行で瞬間とも心は止まることなく働いています
心には休み何もないのです
ずっと働いているんです
わからないんだったら
例えば地球の自転とかね
太陽が燃えることとかね
止まらないでしょ 物質も同じことなんですよ
この休みっていうのは変な単語なんですよ
休み 止まる これは変な単語です
現実にないんです 絶えず物事は物事は変化する
我々の心も活動して変化していく
活動するとは変化すること
変化するとは活動すること
だから太陽が燃えるとは太陽の仕事なんですね
同時に変化するんですね
同じことなんですね 変化とは活動することで
活動するとは変化すること
そこで私たちの心が活動しているんですね
宇宙法則の一つ 心の法則なんです
止まらないんです ずっと仕事をしているんです
思考妄想だけではなく
見る 聞くなどの機能も体を生かしてあげることの心の働きです
心は結構仕事していますよ
何か思考妄想だけじゃない
皆様何か思考妄想だけ気付けてるでしょ？ではない
見ることも心なんです
心がなかったら見られません
聞く 味わう 喋る 体を動かしている
そういうのを全て心がやっていますよ
例えば呼吸すること 心臓が動いていること
すべて心がやっている
で 心はたくさん仕事をやるんだから
ものすごくからくりやってます
科学者が間違っているのはそこらなんですね
例えば心臓細胞 脳細胞なんか見ると
なんか機械的に組み立てているんだと思っているんですね
だから遺伝子わかれば全部わかるんだぞとかね
偉そうなこと言ってますけど
あれ騙されているんです
遺伝子をわかっても何もわからないの
命のことは 心臓は脳の信号で行動しているんだと言ったっても
そうじゃないんです それは心があまり苦労しないで
肉体を動かすためにいろいろからくり
システムを作っているんです
だから我々は精神的にいろいろ変わると
心臓の鼓動も変わるでしょう
ものすごいショックを受けたりとかね
いう場合は 心臓がすぐもう動き始めるんですね
呼吸も変わるでしょう
だからそれは機械的な説明では物足りないんです
なんですごくびっくりしたら
怖くなったら心臓はドキドキするんですかと
あるいは走るために必要ないアドレナリンを作るためやとか
くだらない話でね そうじゃないんです
心の安定したプログラムがガチッと変わっちゃったんです
だからとりあえずガクンと動き出すんですね
すごいエネルギー入れたって
そうすると心臓も呼吸も
もう血液の中でも血圧も何でもかんでも変わってしまいますね
同じシステムだからね
そういうわけで 呼吸であろうが心が管理しているんですね
なんでため息ということがありますね
あれには肉体的な証明
何か説明ある？ないんです
ため息っていうのは悩んで悩んで
はあということでしょう
もう悩んでももうもう疲れちゃう
もうきりがなくて そこでほんのちょっと落ち着きましょうということでため息なんです
というわけで 肉体が体を動かしているんです
あ 何言ってますか 私は
心が体 まだ動いてるんです
生きるとは無停止で活動する心があることです
生きるということはどういうことかというと
無停止で変化する心がありますよということなんです
だからあなたは生きてますよということは
言葉を変えるとあなたに心がありますよと
マイクロフォンは生きてますか？生きてませんね
マイクロフォンには心がないんです
突然変化は起こりません
マイクロフォンが 我々は突然変化を起こしちゃうんです
はい 心を管理する人は命を管理する
だから命って心だから
命って言ったらちょっとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
で 心をしっかりと管理して整理整頓して動かしちゃうと
その人の人生はものすごくしっかりするんです
命を希望通りに管理したければ
心を管理すること 逆に言います
同じことですけど 皆様方はすごく希望通りに生きたいならば
希望をかけていくんじゃなくて
自分の心を見てほしいんです
世間がまだ間違っています
希望通りに生きたいと思って
いっぱい希望を作っちゃって
まっしぐら走り回っちゃうんですね
叶わないんで そんなのは
もうクタクタ疲れて人生失敗して終わっちゃうんです
だから我々仏教から言うのは
希望を追っていってはいけません
だって希望というのは無数にあるでしょう
夢にはリミットがないんだから
そんなのはもう論理的じゃないんだから
置いておいて 心をチェックして心を管理する
そうすると ものの見事に幸福に希望通りに生きていられる
馬鹿げた無数の希望の夢がないんだけど
まあ希望通りに生きているんです
そういうことで心を管理しなくちゃいけないっていうところで
このページを終わります
はい あの宣伝文章で あの
仏教のことをやっちゃうとロボットになるのではないかっていうね
なんか考えもあるんだっていう話があった
私は逆を言いたいんです
心臓のことを管理できないことと同じく
思考妄想の管理もできません
だから私たちには じゃあ心臓はもうちょっとゆっくり行動してもらおうとかね
これはできませんね もうちょっと早くしましょうとかね
思ってもそれはできないんです
まあ呼吸だけはもうもう 1 分で
まあ 4回ぐらい呼吸してやるぞとかね
じゃあ10回やってみるぞとかできますけど
すぐ疲れます 例えば 1 分間一回吸ったり吐いたりしましょうと言ったっても
長持ちはしません  2 3 分でやめる羽目になります
で 呼吸だけいくらか管理できそうなんですけど
いくらでもこんなは疲れる
心臓とかね 血圧とか それはどうにもならない
同じく私言いたいのは
我々の妄想の流れ 思考の流れも勝手に流れるんです
どうすることもできない状態なんです
心は勝手に活動しているんです
人の話を聞かないで より勝手です
生命は心の奴隷です 生命って命あるっていうことは心があることでしょう
心は勝手だろう 私たちは心が言われるように
心の活動に合わせて惨めに生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから尊厳も自由も初めからないんです
だから 人間の世界では命の尊厳
あるいは人間の自由とかね
いろんな言葉があるんだけど
それはまああまり浮いてる単語で
よく生命に精密に入ってみると
何の尊厳もないで 心が言うままに活動してしなくちゃいけない
例えば犬になったら犬の心がまあ決まってるんですね
そのパターンで生きているんです
我々人間になったんだから
人間というプログラムで生きているんです
変えられません 命の尊厳があったら
皆様死にたくないでしょ？歳も取りたくないでしょ？変えられますかね
そんな自由はないんです
決まったループで回転する思考妄想の流れを変えることは
真理を知らない人に不可能です
そこで思考が回転するは妄想がループなんです
同じことを繰り返し繰り返し繰り返し繰り返し
だから レアにまた我々は動物を見てね
犬猫の生活ぶりを見たら
毎日ワンパターンですね
あまり派手な生き方じゃないんだから
すぐ観察しやすいんです
犬の 1 日 猫の 1 日 すぐわかりますね
そうすると ああ この子は毎日ワンパターンで生きてるんだっていうことを言えるでしょ？同じこと私も
みんな毎日ワンパターンで生きてるんです
自己観察してしないんだから気づいてないんです
ちょっと今日からチェックしてみてください
朝何するのか もう見たらほとんど決まってることをやって終わっちゃうんです
だからループで回転しているんだから
そちら自由がないんです
尊厳もないんで 結局はロボットです
最初から人間だけじゃなくて
すべての生命は では次のはい
そのポイントはいい 気をつけて聞かないと大変です
ページごとにいろいろテーマを変えていくんです
次聞きたいポイントは
なんで我々は妄想思考していますか？と
これすごく大事なポイントです
心に活動するためのエネルギーが必要です
心は肉体を動かしているでしょ？心が活動して生きているでしょ
活動するためにエネルギーが必要なんです
エネルギーがなければ
なぜ太陽 地球が自転していますか？エネルギーですよ
相当な膨大なエネルギーです
太陽は燃えているということ
すごいエネルギーですよ
そこで太陽の場合はあまりにも巨大な天体だから
自分自身の圧力でエネルギーが生まれて
核融合が起こっちゃうんですね
そこで核融合から起きたエネルギーでさらに核融合をしているんです
それでずっと燃えている
だから太陽が自分でエネルギーを作って燃えているんです
自分で燃えているんです
我々もそのエネルギーで生きているんです
ということで 心も太陽と同じくすごいエネルギーを作らなくちゃいけないんです
眼耳鼻舌身意に色声香味触法が触れることで
そのエネルギーが生まれるんです
このエネルギーに仏教専門用語でサンカーラというんですね
日本語で業という言葉を書くんです
だから仏教用語は漢字で見て行の意味ではないんです
で なんでこの漢字にしたかとかよくわかりません
だからね 私が作った単語じゃないんだからね
で パーリ語でサンカーラって言うんですね
常にサンカーラ 行が生まれなくちゃあかんのです
いつでも太陽に比較してください
太陽は核融合しますけど
核融合から起きたエネルギーでさらに核融合するんです
それで私たちは目からエネルギーを作る
耳からエネルギーを作る
鼻からエネルギーを作る
で どうやって目からエネルギー作るんですかね
目は目で何もエネルギー起こりません
物理的な変化だけです
そこで目で見て認識するんですね
見た あの見た瞬間 見たと思った瞬間でエネルギーが生まれるんです
そのように六根がありますからね
六根からずっとエネルギーが生まれているんです
源に身心から起こるエネルギーにリミットがあるので
心は勝手に妄想 思考することで絶えず生きるエネルギーを作っています
目で見て生きるエネルギーを作りましょうと言っても
リミットがあります いくらでもエネルギー作れません
耳で音を聞いてエネルギー
精神的なエネルギーを作りましょうと思っても飽きちゃいます
聞きたくないということになっちゃうんです
だから肉体とおっしゃると
肉体疲労というものがありますから
物質だからね 物質には疲労というものあるんですね
だからずっと仕事はできません
それで源に身心からのエネルギーがちょっと足らないのです
それで心が勝手に意で妄想するんです
たまに思考もするんです
これですごいエネルギーが生まれてくるのです
というわけで 大変なことになります
存在欲がある生命は 妄想
思考から生まれる力に固執しているんです
だから皆様も生きていきたいという気持ちがあるんだから
目耳鼻よりも自分の妄想を大事にするんです
自分の考えることが大事にするんです
それは何といっても止めません
変えたくはないんです
そのまま思考妄想したいのです
例えば 私 こういうパワーポイント作っちゃうと
話はつまらないんですよ
話っていうのは直接喋った方が結構面白く喋れますけど
まあ仕方がない パワーポイント作りますからね
これは問題は私のこの発音の問題あるんですよ
いろいろなまりもあったり
時々ざっとさの差が分からなくなったり
いろいろありますから
長音 短音 語音間違ったりとかね
いろいろ問題ありあるんだから
一応文字にしましょうとしたんだけど
文字にしちゃうと対話が消えちゃうんですね
だから言いたかったのは別な例なんですけど
例えば私の話に乗って
それに合わせて思考するならば
皆様のすごいエネルギーが生まれる
眠くならないです しかし
皆様方は長い間持ってきた思考パターンと妄想パターンがあるんでしょ
そこは慣れているんですよ
慣れているんだから それをやめたくないんです
それに執着しているんです
それで皆様方は自分の勝手な妄想をしながら
ついでに話を聞く そうすると妄想の邪魔になっちゃいますから
じゃあ話を聞かないことにしましょうと
寝てやるぞということになっちゃうんです
寝ても妄想は止まりません
はい そこで言いたかったのは
やっぱりこの書く人が持っている思考パターン
妄想ループを変えたくはないんですね
やばいと思っちゃうんです
エネルギーがなくなる
はい では 生命エネルギーだと思ったら
なんかすごいありがたいと感じちゃうでしょ？た単純にあるんです
妄想すればするほど生きるエネルギーが生まれるんだと
それだけ聞いちゃうと
なんかありがたくなっちゃうんです
ちょっと落とし穴があります
ちょっとのところじゃないんです
存在欲をかき立てるだけ
この思考妄想で大したことをしないんだ
ただ 存在欲をかき立てる
生きていきたい気持ちをなんとかなんとかかき立ててあげる
貪瞋痴の刺激が妄想思考を作り出します
そこで妄想思考を作り出すのは貪瞋痴なんですね
だから太陽の場合は水素
が融合する そんな感じで
我々の心の中で貪瞋痴という
貪というのは欲 瞋というのは怒り
嫌な気持ち それから無知
真理 何も知らないという ３つが融合するんです
して思考にするんです
生命は無明と渇愛という原因で限りのない輪廻転生して苦しみから抜け...脱出できずいるのだと説かれています
これはお釈迦様の言葉なんですね
だから無明と渇愛があります
そこは融合してエネルギーができちゃって
さらに無明と渇愛を作るんです
そこを融合して また生きるエネルギーを作る
生きることは苦なんです
苦です これもわからない
だから無明ということですね
そこで苦しみである生きることがずっと続くのです
これはこの肉体に限って皆様考えるんだから誤解しますけど
この宇宙の法則なんですね
まあたまたまここで肉体が見えるだけでね
宇宙エネルギーなんです
心も宇宙的なエネルギーなんです
だからそのエネルギーがずっと
変わって変わって変わって続くんですね
それを輪廻というのです
だから私という個人で物事を考える人には輪廻わからないんです
自分がいないとただエネルギーの塊だと
エネルギーが流れているだけだとわかる人には
エネルギーの流れがわかることはできます
それは輪廻転生だ 大体日本の方々
かなり輪廻転生に対してはよくわかりませんとかね
信じたくはないとかいろいろ言ってますよ
よくわかりませんという人も
信じたくないという方々も
私という私 田中 私 太郎とかね
そういう一時的な現象にしがみすぎているんですね
そこを土台にして考えとするんです
そうすると何もわからなくなっちゃうんです
普通の妄想で感情が増える
しかし 成長ではなく より不幸に堕落するんです
普通の妄想っていうのは貪瞋痴の働きなんですね
これは悪いものなんです
だから生命は自動的に成長しないんです
自動的に堕落するんです
普通の思考も人格向上
心の進化には役に立たない
それから人間が思考しているでしょ
妄想だけじゃないんです
思考は必要なものでしたんだからといって
何も人格向上していないんです
我々は今 ものすごい IT 世界で生きているんですね
ネット依存時代で生きているんですけど
人格向上していますかね
十年十五年前  IT 世界ではなかったんだから
そこでいろんな金具を作って
ネット依存社会を作っちゃったんですね
TWITTER や FACEBOOK の世界が作ったんですね
それがなければ生きていられませんと
では 人格はどうですかね
堕落するんであって 成長しないんです
はい そういうことで 普通の人間の思考
妄想はそのまま放っておくことはできません
これはもうどんどんどんどんどん堕落する道で
堕落していくといくと
微妙にこれはあかんと気づくんですね
気づいて ちょこちょこっと間違いなく思考して
ちょっと成長するんだけど
成長した時点でまた思考妄想して
また落ちる そうやって回転するんです
はい そこでいくらかもう理論のところは終わったとしましょう
それで私たちが何するべきかというと
心を見て心を管理するということは必要になってくるんです
自然に任せてはいけません
自然の流れに任せちゃうと
ろくなことにならないんです
不幸は決まっている 堕落することが決まっている
はい まず心にアクセスする方法
目耳からはそれほど簡単じゃないんです
アクセスできますけど
それには結構仏教を学んでおかないと
仏教は何も知らなくても
思考妄想から自分の心にアクセスすることはできます
はい まず妄想の勉強をしましょう
妄想とは何か 感情から現れる概念の回転
感情っていうのは貪瞋痴ですね
貪瞋痴が融合して何か概念が生まれる
そういう概念が回転していきますね
皆様 各自の妄想をちょっとチェックしてみてください
いつもワンパターンなんです
同じことを妄想するということです
面白いこと 例えば 何か妄想があって
それに気づいて時間を見てみるんですね
その時 大体次の日も同じ時間で同じ妄想をするんです
まあ変わることもありますけど
大体同じことなんです
例えば明日目が覚める
その時どんな妄想をするのかと
次の日も同じ妄想をするんです
ということで 感情が融合して現れる概念の回転
新たな発見 一切起こりません
ひらめきはありません
妄想することで新たなアイデアが浮かんだとはありえないんです
何もひらめきはないんです
ただ回転するだけ リスみたいにね
リスにはランニングミルというものを作ってあげるんですよ
その中に入って走っているんです
激しい依存症になります
そこで我々は激しく妄想に依存するんです
もう妄想せざるを得ない
どうしても妄想したいんです
精神的に病気な方々がいるでしょ
あの決まってるパターンの妄想ばっかりしている
いくら言ってもまたそのパターンに戻るんです
それでカウンセリングを喋る時でも面白いんですよ
この精神的な問題の方々は
つるがすく相手に質問して
自分の妄想パターンを正当化してもらうんです
直してもらわない 直してあげようとしたら
そう言われたっても こういうこういうことでっていうことで自分を正当化するんです
それは依存症なんです
我々 精神病気ないかもしれませんだけど
妄想依存症はあるんです
現実と関係ありません
妄想と現実は関係ないんですね
自分だけの世界で客観性はない
自分だけで作った世界の中にいるんですね
客観性がないんですね
たまに決定したり 結論を出したりするが
すべて現実逃避です 時々妄想して妄想して
はい 決めた なんとかやるぞと
あれやらない方がいいんです
あれ 現実離れなんです
例えば 派手な例を言いますね
自分がある人のことを怒っている
その人の悪いことばっかり妄想している
自分に言ったことを繰り返し繰り返し思い出したりしている
その人でやったことを繰り返し繰り返し思い出したりして妄想している
そこでいてもたってもいられなくなる
それで はい 決めた あいつのひとつ殴ってやると
これやらない方がいいんです
その人は関係ないんです
その人はもうたまたま何か言ったかもしれませんし
そんなこと考えてもないし
あの人をいじめようと馬鹿にしようとそんな気持ちもなく
たまたま言ったことでしょうし
その人の生き方でしょうし
なんであなたは殴られなくちゃいけないんですかとびっくりするんですよ
これは派手な例で 常に我々は妄想して何かやったら
妄想して何かやると いつでもそれは現実離れで外れるんです
仕事をする時でも 妄想して仕事を当たると
仕事はうまくいってないんです
料理する時でも妄想でやっちゃうとうまくいかないんです
貪瞋痴はネガティブエナジーです
人生は不幸に陥れます
貪瞋痴で妄想していると
それはネガティブなんです
感情は節度を超えると命は破壊されて
さらに苦しみを感じられるところに再び生が現れます
本当に死にますよ 節度を超えちゃうと
妄想が いくらでもいますよ
そういう人々は 自殺の人々はどうか
妄想して妄想してもう耐えられなくなっちゃう
そこで結論するんです
行動しましょうと 行動は自殺なんです
いわゆるこの肉体であの苦しみは耐えられないんです
そうすると その人に別な体
苦しみ耐えられる より良い苦しみに
より良いじゃない より強い苦しみに耐えられる肉体が現れるんです
これでいいんですかね
仏教ですごいわかりやすく地獄の一場所というのはそういうことなんです
いくら妄想しても結論がないので
妄想の流れに終わりがないんです
これよく覚えてください
妄想っていうのは結論がないんです
ただ何か考えている よく見ると概念が回転しているだけ
同じパターンだから結論がないんです
例えば あの人はなんで私のことを気に入らないでしょうかと
こういうこともしました
こういうことを言いました
結論がある？ないんです
それだったら調べた方がいいでしょうに
その人に聞いて 私の気持ちでは
あなたは私のことを気に入らないみたいですと
どういうところで具体的に気に入らなくなっているんでしょうかと聞いた方がいい
聞かないでしょ 聞かない
自分だけで妄想する それで結論がないんです
有効に使うべき時間 いわゆる寿命ですよ
を浪費してしまいます
妄想ってとんでもない恐ろしいもんなんです
我々は依存しているのはわかりますよ
だからっていいわけじゃない
これ大事な時間 生きる時間
命短いんですよ この生きる時間を有効に生きるということはできなくなるんです
時間無駄に無駄に無駄にしちゃう
無駄に年を取る お釈迦様の言葉の中で
妄想にふけっている人々のことは
無駄に年取ったと言うんですね
老人と言ったっても 老人というのはすごい経験のある
知識のある立派な人なんですね
ただ 無駄に年取った人
まだあります 妄想の悪いところは
妄想することで無明が強くなります
自己管理 自由などがなくなって
ロボットのように生きるんです
妄想する人はみんなロボットなんです
前向きに明るく活発に生きることができなくなります
妄想する人は暗いんですよ
例えば ちっちゃな子供たちに
ものすごいちっちゃな子供たちには妄想する材料がないでしょ
人生経験もないんだから
ものすごく明るいでしょ
これは目の前のことで
精一杯生きてるんですね
だからちっちゃな子供の成長ってものすごく早い
これでどんどんゆっくりになっちゃうんです
高校生になってくると
ほとんど成長がストップして
同じところで回転するようになっちゃうんです
例えばね  2歳 まあ 2歳程度で子供をね
言語をいくつか喋る環境に入れちゃうと
3歳になってくると何のことなくいくつかの言語を喋ります
すごい成長早いんです
私たちにはできませんね
だからそれ秘密はいたって簡単
妄想してないんです  子供に我々は妄想の訓練させますよ
物語いろいろね 教えてあげて
絵本を読んであげたりしてるんです
でも大人が妄想する子供は
ある意味で妄想しないんです
子供はあるいは現実的に楽しい気持ちを作ることに頑張っているんです
あの人本当ですか？じゃあ我々よりもいや
あれは嘘です 何のことなく言います
嘘と知っているくせに
もう一度言ってくださいということですよ
ね 妄想は仕方がないと思っているが
不善行為です そこで我々大人がなんで暗いんですかね？で
妄想もする それだけじゃない
妄想は仕方かなくやってますけど
これは不善行為なんです
いわゆる悪行為なんです
悪行為には悪 悪行為は悪になります
だから人生不幸になります
妄想しても不幸になります
もう決まってるんです
不幸 悩み 苦しみ 落ち込み
堕落を好むなら 簡単にできる妄想に執着することです
だから不幸になりたければ
どうぞ妄想してくださいなんです
人生堕落したければ 極端な暗い人間になりたければ
どうぞ妄想してください
妄想やりやすい 慣れてます
寿命を短くしたければ妄想することです
どんな人間もだいたい 120
130歳 まあ伸ばしていったとしても150歳の力が持ってます
認知症にもなりませんし
寝たきりにもなりませんよ
正しい心管理したならば
でも今更そんな話聞いても体壊れてますから
期待しない方がいいんです
ただ ちっちゃい時からもう妄想をしない訓練していたならば
なんのことなく150歳になります
この認知症といって脳が壊れることも妄想の結果なんです
はい 妄想の勉強はそれでは次
思考の勉強をしましょう
思考とは考えることですね
妄想は考えることじゃないんです
ただ勝手に書いてるんです
考える場合は自分で意図的に考えなくちゃいけないんです
客観的なデータがなければ思考できません
データが欲しいんです
例えば数学の問題出しますね
子供に 子供はその時妄想しないんですね
思考するんです 思考するためデータが必要です
だから 今まで学んだ数学の理論に照らし合わせて
どうやってこの問題解決するのかと
単純な足し算引き算するときでも
あれデータなんです 頭の中でデータがやりとりしているんです
だから 引き算足し算するときでも
数学の問題を解くときでも思考しているんです
試験に行って受験するときでも思考しているんです
自動的じゃないんでしょ？そこで試験の問題集を見てね
妄想しちゃうとアウト
わからないことがあると
それを理解するために
人生に役に立つことを企画するために思考します
我々はわからないことが現れちゃうと
それはわかりたいんだからデータを取り入れてみる
それ思考なんです それからよりもっと便利に生きたい
もっと楽に生きたいとか
何か目的が出てくると
だったらどうすればいいのかと思考するんです
例えば 体の調子も悪いんだから
もっと健康にいい食べ物を食べたいなと思うと
それについて勉強するんです
健康にいい食べ物は何なのか
自分の体に合う食べ物は何なのかとか
それは思考ですね 結論が出たところで
その思考の流れが止まります
これ思考のいいところなんですね
例えば自分の体にコレステロールが高い
それでコレステロールが控える食べ物は何なのかと
今まで食べ方だったらダメよと
それで考えて いろいろネットでデータを調べてみる
料理本とか見て あ こういうこういうこういう料理作って食べた方がいいでしょう
料理の仕方はこういう風に変えた方がいいでしょうとかね
結論に達するでしょ それから考える必要ないんですね
終わり それから実行するだけです
だから思考で人はダメにならないんです
結論でストップするんだから
結論が出たところで その思考の流れが止まります
それから別のテーマをで思考します
それから別なことを考えるんです
だから 妄想ではなく 思考だけだったらすごくありがたいんです
妄想する時間で英語を勉強するとかね
フランス語を勉強するとかね
何か新しい稽古事を何かやるとかね
すごくいいことでしょ？妄想しないで
その時間思考ですから
結構驚きます はい 科学
学問などは思考の結果なんですね
科学世界あります あれは思考の結果ですね
学問ともなりますね いろんな学問
それも思考してできたものなんです
例えば考古学っていうのもあるでしょ
古いものは土の中に埋葬されたままであったっていうのも学問じゃないんですね
それで思考を入れて 土のレイヤーを見てどんな年代ですかとかね
カーボンテストに入れて年代を決めたりとかね
形から掘り出した時 時じゃなくてまあ土器でしたっけ
そこで模様を見て これは縄文時代
何々時代とかね 言ったりとかね
そうやってこの思考パターン
システムがあるんですね
この思考システムは考古学というんです
現代社会も思考の結果であり
妄想の結果ではありません
今 我々の現代社会 あれ思考の結果なんです
皆様の携帯も このホールも
この照明も音声もすべて思考の結果です
妄想してできたものはないんです
貪瞋痴で思考するのは主流ですが
良い結果に導いても必ず副作用として想定外の悪
悪 悪結果が現れます これを覚えておきましょう
我々は思考しますよ あれ
貪瞋痴で思考します どうすればもっと金入りますか？とかね
どうすればあと 1キロぐらい痩せるんですか？とかね
どうすれば髪の毛の本数が増えますか？とかね
いろいろ考えます あれは貪瞋痴の思考でしょ
例えば今使っているパソコン系のね
いろんなタブレットもあるし
携帯もあるし ノートパソコンもあるし
でっかいパソコンもコンピューターもあるしね
あれは思考の結果なんですね
しかし 貪瞋痴で思考したんです
そこで面白いことは 良い結果は出ているんだけど
同時に想定外の悪い結果もあるんです
なぜかというと 貪瞋痴が悪い結果出します
これ避けられないんです
あれは貪瞋痴の本性です
昔の人々は一番体にいいものっていうのは
自然に生えているものは取って食べることです
鳥と動物と同じ でも人間がそれでも物足らないと思って畑作ることにしたんです
森に入って食べるものを取ろうということはやめちゃったんです
そうすると 食べるものの
エネルギーがね 変わるんです
いろんな種類の植物と一緒に育てる芋と
我々は畑で作る芋は違うんです
だから栄養的に言えばかなり違います
見れば そこでさらに農業を発達しちゃって
これはコマーシャルプロダクションになって商売になっちゃったんです
昔は食べるために畑作って
今儲かるために畑作っている
どうなったんですかね
必ず食べるものに体に悪いものばっかり溜まって溜まっていっちゃうんです
だから我々は今 現代習慣
生活習慣病っていうものはすべて食べる
すべてではなくて もうもう 60%
70%ぐらいは食べるものの結果なんです
期待しなかったことが現れたんです
昔は高血圧はなかったんです
昔は糖尿病はなかったんです
今あるんですね あの文化のガンとかね
そういうのは文化社会にあるんですよ
文化以前ではなかったんですね
まあ長生きできているのかよくわかりませんだけど
自然の中で生きているんだから
誰かにやられちゃうということはありましたからね
で それから環境どうですか？破壊しているでしょう
空気は壊れてもう汚染しているでしょう
そこでネット依存ですから
今はね みんなの人格が壊れているんですね
社会性がなくなっているんですね
人と喋れなくなっているんです
人間と仲良くすることはできなくなっている
わがままそのもの そのものになっているんです
だから貪瞋痴で思考すると必ず副作用があるんです
原発ですよ 貪瞋痴で エネルギーが現れます
といっぱい安く そのそこもいいんです
電気はうまいです 安いんですかね
それの副作用の方があれよりはるかに高くつくんです
はい これ貪瞋痴の思考のそこを覚えておきましょう
だから いくら時代が発展しても
いくら社会が発展しても
人間の生きる上で問題は絶えないんです
いつだって我々は矛盾の生き方をしなくちゃいけないんです
現代 私たちは矛盾に満ちた満ちた世界に生きているんです
はい 次のページに行きます
善思考 悪思考があります
思考の場合は善思考と悪思考と区別することはできます
妄想の場合はできません
悪いものです 欲 怒り 嫉妬
他に害を与える目的などに基づいて
いくら客観的に 現実的に
具体的に 科学的に思考しても
それは悪思考で悪化になります
原子爆弾を作る人々 科学者たちがすごい科学的に客観的に考えていますよ
しかし 怒りに憎しみでしょ
悪化になります 大量破壊兵器を開発する人々は超一流の科学者たちなんです
超一流のエンジニアたちなんです
世界の有名な大学で首席で卒業して
大教授たちなんです だから彼らがアホなことを考えていないんです
しっかりと科学的に考えている
しかし 貪瞋痴ですね 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみ 金儲け だから
例えば薬開発の場合は
病気を治すことはもう二の次なんです
金儲けが大事なんです
だから我々はいつだって薬だと思って毒を飲まなくちゃいけないんです
他の生命を助ける気持ち
慈悲喜捨に基づく気持ち
無明を破る目的の思考などは善です
だから いくら儲かるかではなく
どうすれば人の役に立つのかと考えた方がいいんじゃない？私はどうすればもっと人の役に立つ人間になるのかと
どのようにすればみんなにかける迷惑が少なくなるのかと
そういう風に考えたらどうですかね
社会に 周りに 家族に迷惑をかけていて
これは控えましょうと
どうすればいいんですか？ものすごいびっくりする考えが現れてくるんです
で 我々はどうすれば儲かるかってことしか考えてないんです
それは副作用があります
仏道も正見正思惟で始まります
仏道というのは八正道なんですよ
八正道の第1項目は正見
2番目は正思惟 だから仏教は正しい思考から始まるんです
信仰から始まりません
仏教は宗教じゃないんです
科学者よりも明確に副作用の一切ない思考から始まるんです
だから人類に幸福ですよ
みんな仏教的な思考をするならば
人類だけじゃなくて すべてのその他の生命も幸福になります
出家の場合 お釈迦様が言うのは生命
神々 梵天 みんなの幸福のために歩きなさいと
思考を正してるんです
だから仏道は正見正思惟で始まるんです
えーと うーん  1時間も行きましたね
35分です  では後半始まります
はい これから じゃあもう妄想は悪いことになって
思考は善悪両方ありますけど
で 善思考をした方がいいんじゃないかなというところで終わりました
でもこう簡単じゃないんですよ
言うのは理解するのはいいんだけどもね
やるのはちょっと難しい
まずブッダの言葉をちょっと紹介します
パンダランチャパランチッタンドゥラッカンドゥンニワレヤンウジュンカルティメターリウスカルウテジャナ
意味は 意味は心は弱い
揺らぐ 守り難い 悪に走ることを制御できない
しかし 智者は職人が矢をまっすぐに伸ばすように
心をまっすぐに する 心をしっかり育てる
だからといって簡単と思うなよ
これ大変です 心が 次の言葉はドゥンニッガハスラフノヤッタカーミニパーティニ
心は制御し難い 速い 好き勝手に働く
どうもなんかあまりにも凶暴な野生の獣のようなものなのです
私たちは怯えて はい わかりましたという風にロボットになるしかないんです
それは逆に調教することはこれから説明します
一番簡単なのは道徳なんですね
あまり大げさ大げさことじゃないんですね
悪を犯して生きることをやめる
だから我々はとにかくその際よくあるんだから生きていきたいでしょ
生きることの助けになるならば
悪いことでもしちゃうんですね
だから結果良ければ方法はどうでもいいやと思ってるでしょ
だからバレなかったらどうでも構いませんよという感じで生きているんです
そこをやめましょう たとえ生きるためであっても
悪いことはやめる これ簡単じゃないんです
それから善行を積む 普段誰も善行しないんです
したくないんです それは心はそうなんです
獣だから だからわざわざちょっと無理をしてでも善行を積む
で 仏教ではちゃんと戒律っていうものはリストアップして教えているんです
これは宗教的ではないんです
心理学的に心が調教する
成長する項目を見て選んで
これこれこれ守りなさい
宗教でも戒律はあります
それも信仰的なんですね
神に言われましたと だから守るしかないでしょうと
例えば人が強盗をしたら手を切断する必要ないでしょ
女性が誰かの男とちょっとちょこちょこ喋っていたからって
その女性を捕まってきて
公で鞭打つ必要ないでしょ
でも仕方がない 神がそういう法律を決めたんだからということになっているんです
ああいうのは迷信で盲信で
もう非科学的なんです
仏教の戒律はそうじゃなくて
すごく科学的なんです
皆様も今日最初に五戒っていうのをね
よく見てください 宗教は関係ないんです
生き方なの 正しい生き方
そういうことで あの戒律を守る
次 わがままで感情で悪結果を顧みず
勝手に働く心の本情を発見する
この戒律を守ることで
あの で 自我でっかい人間になるんじゃなくて
素直に守ってるんです
素直に守っていくと何か発見しますか？これって相当難しい
戒律を守るよりは破りたいんですよ
だから あの気持ちを抑えて守っているんです
嘘つきたいんです その気持ちを抑えて嘘をつかないことにするんです
そこで何か見える 心ってとんでもないわがまま
悪の塊であることを発見するんです
その願いなんです だから
心を見るために戒律を守るんです
儀式じゃないんです どんな宗教も儀式の塊
仏教も宗教になったでしょ？歴史の流れで儀式の塊ですよ
あんなのはもう何の意味もないんです
どんな服着るのかとか
例えば日本の場合は宗派によってこのもう違うんですね
何の意味もない 法要の時はなんか帽子まで被って来るんですね
なんか私 今日の何か分かりませんだけどね
ここでなんかなんかありましてね
帽子被って何やるのかと
ドラマじゃないんだからね
歌舞伎じゃないんだからと
だから今日そうでしょうしね
もうお祭りで終わってるんですね
そういうためにお釈迦様が戒律を教えてないんです
戒律はバッジじゃないんです
ネクタイじゃないんです
私も戒律を守っている
私は肉魚食べませんよとかね
勝手にしろよと どうでもいいんです
そんなそうじゃなくて
なくて 嘘つかないとかね
与えられたものは取らないとかね
やってみると 自分の汚れた心を発見する
それがポイントです 戒律を守れない卑劣な自分を発見したら
もう戒律を守ったことにするんです
だから やっぱり情けないんだと自分が
真面目に頑張りたいんだけど
どうも心が足を引っ張っているんだと
そうやって戒律を守ることで
我が心はどんなものかと発見するところを目指してください
苦労してでも道徳を守る人は幸福になる
それだけじゃないんです
道徳を守る人はものすごく守られます
だから社会で 会社で どこで問題は起きません
家族の中で 友達の間で
生きる上では問題は起きません
必ず守られます だからそういう利益があります
次の実践は集中力なんです
妄想するとは一切集中力しないことなんです
心っていうのは宇宙のエネルギーだから
膨大なエネルギーがあるんですよ
これがもうまんきり集中していないんだから
何の力もなくなる 風に立っても集中するとすごいエネルギーでしょ
そこで妄想するとは 心を集中しない意味なんです
それでちょびっと集中力訓練するんです
例えば 呼吸をじーっと見て
ちょっと決まってる時間ね
10 分  20 分  30 分とかね
呼吸が出たり入ったり
出たり入ったりするその感覚だけ見てみようとする
その時は妄想するんだから
恐れがあるんだから 何か言葉を使わなくちゃいけないんです
例えば まあ入っている
吸っている 吐いている
吸っているとか その言葉を唱えてみるんです
で 呼吸だけ見ているんで
呼吸っていうのは同じだけでしょう
それに集中すると心がすごい強くなっているんです
それから仏教ではテーマがいくつかありまして
これ仏随念 ブッダってどういう人でしょうか
いろいろ本を読んだり勉強したりする
で それも集中力になるんです
で 法 教えはどういうものかと
聖者はどんなものかとか
テキストにデータありますから
そういうものは念じたりすることができます
それから無常というブッダの説かれた真理ありますね
無常を発見する いろんなもの
生きることはこうと言っているんだから
いい加減ではなくて 生きることはなんでこうでしょうかと
それで自分の毎日の生き方をチェックしてみる
すると結構苦しく生きていることがわかってくる
他の人々の命を見る 野生の動物たちの生き方を見てみる
そうすると みんな大変苦しんで生きているんだということが見えてくる
それは集中力なんです
あの生物学者 例えば昆虫の研究をする生物学者とかいるでしょ
あれ 集中力ですよ いろんなところで昆虫だけ探している
その集中力が昆虫を探したって
何も人格向上しませんだからこういうものをやってほしいんです
面白くできるんですよ
呼吸を見ることだけでもね
1 日 3回  10 分  10 分だけ呼吸を見てみると
結構集中力が起きて人生落ち着いてくるんです
生きるために なんか生きる戦いにもうチャレンジできるようになってる
はい 妄想の時間が減るので心は成長します
そこで理論は 集中すると妄想の時間カットされちゃうんですね
例えば呼吸 吐いてます
吸ってます 吐いてます
言っていると 妄想できなくなってるんですね
妄想する時間カットされているんです
あの悪い時間 危険な時間
それで心は成長します
落ち着いて失敗なく少ない
生きられます これ もともと弱い心が強くなるので
より明るく活発に生きられます
あの子供の頃あった脳活発性が
あの元気がまた現れてきます
はい ここで集中力のポイントは
この妄想しない時間わざわざ作る
それもブッダに説かれた方法で
昆虫探しじゃない ないんです
あるいはまあ ここら辺何工でしたっけ？ タイトウ
タイトウ タイトウこの植物を全部調べますとかね
まあいいです それを集中力なんですけど
あまり人格向上には役に立たない
貪瞋痴でやってるんだから
金もかかるし 結構疲れちゃうんですね
自分がもうタイトウこの全ての植物の図鑑作っちゃっても
誰も本買ってくれないしね
面白くないと そうするとなんか
なんかおかしいんですね
だから呼吸やってください
すごい役に立ちます はい
次の訓練は気づきなんですね
今流行っていること マインドフルネスとか
今ここで自分が何をやっているのかと気づいている
この大騒ぎしていますけど
すごいシンプルなことで
今ここで私は何をやっているの？と気づくんです
これがブッダのヴィパッサナー瞑想でもあって
悟りに達する瞑想でもありますね
一切妄想ができなくなっちゃうんです
そうすると自動で心が成長していくんです
今の瞬間の行為を確認することで妄想ができなくなります
体の動きから始めて 能力が上がる次第に心の働きにも気づいてみます
これ難しいんだから マインドフルネスはね
まず手を上げることは下げること
歩くこと 物を取ること
運ぶこと 今やっていることをね
気づいてやるんです その時も言葉を使った方が完璧安全なんです
西洋の方は言葉を使うと教えているかどうか分かりませんだけど
仏教伝統では必ず言葉を使うんです
言葉を使わないと妄想も一緒にやっちゃうんですね
例えばこのペットボトルを取りたければ
手を伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
掴む 取る 上げると言葉はかかるんです
それで妄想がなくなってしまうんです
これは戻す場合は まあ戻す
戻す 戻す 戻す 戻す 置く
置く 離す 手を戻すと実況するんですね
それで妄想がなくなるんです
まず体の動きでやって能力が上がるんですよ
能力が上がったら 心の動きも
今こいつは何やってるの？と見えてくるんです
そうするとそちらにも言葉をかけて
今悩んでいる 今怒っている
今落ち込んでいる 今興奮している
というのは 自分という気持ちじゃない
こいつは という感じで心を見られます
今弱くなっている 今揺らいでいる
今力がなくなっている
こいつの こいつというのは心のことなんです
そういうふうに自分の心を見られます
まず体から始めましょう
心の病がなくなります
これで心は完治します
すべての精神病気がなくなります
智慧が現れるための環境を備えます
あの智慧という我々に全くないものあります
無明の反対 無明はネガティブで智慧はポジティブエネルギーなんです
だからネガティブに生きてるんだから
ポジティブがわからないんですね
これ ポジティブエネルギーが現れるために環境が現れてあげます
この気づく はい これで心整理をしましょう
今日の今日のテーマに入りましょうか
本当は今日のテーマに沿いて喋る必要は何もないんです
いわゆる何でしたっけ？今日のテーマは
考える時間でしょ いらん
そんなに 妄想をやめてこれやっちゃえば
その人は正しく 科学的に
客観的に 具体的にのを考えているんです
だから考える能力を育てる特別方法はないんです
邪魔をなくすだけです
例えばお釈迦様の教えで修行する人々は
みんなものすごい知恵の達人ですよ
びっくりするんです 私はあるお坊さん知ってます
ネットで知ってますけど
あの年取ってから出家した人で
仏教学やってないんです
我々みたいに もう山荘で何書いてるのほとんどわからない
しかし 瞑想している 瞑想はもう達しているんです
そこで喋る時はもう 2時間半でも何のことなく喋るんです
びっくりするんです あの智慧に
だから私もネットでこれそのお坊さんの説法なんか入れちゃうと
YOUTUBE でそのままジーッているんです
聞いて ちょっとつまらないな
長すぎ その気持ちがないんです
トイレに行きたかったんだけど
終わりまで聞いている
もうあれはこらえた あの力
どこから来るんですかね
だから仏典知らないんだから
そこら辺 そこら辺でたとえ話をとって喋ってるんです
純粋にブッダの止まらぬ真理を語っているんです
経典に照らしましても
一切間違いないんです
だから妄想をやめる訓練すれば
思考能力のことはもう気にしないでください
いわゆる我々は服を洗う時は
服を綺麗にすることに心配する
するしかないんです どんな汚れがあるのかと
汚れを見てそれを落としちゃえば自動で服は綺麗です
だから話しないことにしましょう
これは妄想を制御して減らすだけで
客観的な思考能力が現れます
これは自動で現れます
それでも仕方がないんだから
さっさとあの思考の方法を教えます
客観的なデータ次第 思考の訓練
考える訓練 何でも考えるものではありません
何でも考えていけませんよ
止まらなくて 妄想で夢物語で終わります
だから考える力といって
馬鹿げた何でも考えてはいけません
例えば仏教では宇宙はどうなっているのかとか
ビッグバンはどうなっているのかとか
そんなものはやめなさいと
夢物語で終わりますよと
きりがないテーマなんですね
客観的なデータに基づいて考えて判断します
自分に入るデータでって考えましょう
そうすると そんな膨大なデータ入るわけないでしょう
見るもの 読んでる本 見る映画
そういう風に自分の心に入るデータから
これでからこうです これだからこうですとデータで考えるんです
あのデータ飛ばして推測に行ってはいけない
いけません 科学者よくやりますね
ということはそうであるかもしれません
こうなるかもしれません
とかね そこまで行く必要はない
例えば ある映画を見る
これはヒットする映画
この監督が初めて作った映画
それで ああ この監督の初めての作
初めての作品で 結構みんなにアピールしちゃってヒットしまったと
で ヒットした理由は何なのかと
それで映画の内容でしょ
映画のメッセージでしょ
撮り方でしょ そういうもの
ストーリーの組み立て
スクリーンプレイといいますけど
スクリーンプレイは監督が決めるんですね
どんな場面を先に出して
どんな場面後に出すのかどうかね
時々映画では最後に見せるべきことは最初に見せる場合もあります
見せちゃってそれからストーリーに行くんです
そういういろいろやり方があるんです
そこで この監督の最初の映画で
もう内容がみんな受け取って
それで あ こういうことでこうなってる
こういうことでこうなってると
そこで思考を止めてください
それから初作品はこういうものだから
この人は天才に違いありません
次の作品は世界的にヒットするかもしれません
次はハリウッドに呼ばれるかも
くだらんことをやめてください
その人は次の作品できなくて
そのえたい知らない人間で死ぬかもしれませんよ
知らない そんなの だからデータで止めてください
それは訓練してください
そうです この水を飲んでみたら
うん おいしいで止めてください
大概  どこの水ですかね
水道水でしょうかね 皆さん
谷川なんとか崖なんとかの名水
本当かどうかよくわかりませんけどもね
まあ飲んでまずくはない
それで十分です なぜならば
こちらにこう書いてるんだけど
騙すこともできますね
騙すこともできます だから決定しない
あ こう書いてるんだから
確実にこれは谷川 なんたらなんたらの水やと
と決定する必要はないです
データで止める じゃあ
科学能力あるならば この水の成分は何なのかと調べてもいいんですよ
ラボに行ってね 成分だけ見て
このメーカー出すどんな水も同じわけじゃないんです
同じ内容あるわけじゃない
そういう風に物事を考えると面白くない？面白くないます
皆さんは まああの水だからね
こういう成分に決まっているとかね
すぐもう思考しないで
終わっちゃうんですね
だからこの 思考の仕方はすごく面白いです
仏教的に言うと このメーカーの水をいっぱい飲んでくださいではなくて
このペットボトルの水はまあ結構よろしいんだと
どこかに行ってラーメン食べたら気に入ったら
あの店のラーメンは日本一やとか決めないでください
私はある日行ってラーメン食べた
すごく美味しかった で
データだけ 日本一か日本二かはわかりません
だけど友達にもそういうことだから
あなたも行ってみたら？と
友達が行って食べたら
まあ普通でしたね あれは
その通りです それで何を飲む？あなたはとかね
あなたの味覚はおかしくない？あれは美味しいに決まってるとかね
馬鹿な喧嘩しないでください
データで止めるんです
友達に勧めたんだけど
友達はまあ別に普通でしたよと言ったら
あ そうですか それデータだからね
それで終える 終わるんです
それ思考の訓練なんです
正しく考える訓練なんです
新しいデータが入り次第
結論を訂正できるように意見を保留状態に保ちます
これすごく大事なんです
自分が決めるんで 何かデータで決めるんだけど
保留してください もしかすると新たなデータが入るかもしれません
新たなデータが入ったら
この意見を訂正しなくちゃいけないんです
だから思考能力ある人は結論出して止めることはないんです
いろんな結論に達するんだけど
すべて保留状態 例えばあれは私はこの大学の方々と仲良くしていた時代で
みんなもう何年も苦労してデータ集めて
何かレポート 研究レポートを出したりするんだけど
ものすごい緊張してるんですよ
発表すると ものすごい
なぜかというと 誰かが何かこれは違いますと言われちゃうと
ガクーンと落ち込むんです
態度消沈しちゃうんです
大変ショック来ちゃう
だからあれは思考能力ないからなんです
だから自分でもろくに調べていないものがあるんだけど
ごまかそうとするんですね
そういうのは だから自分が自分データで言って結論を出しましたけど
先輩の教授たちがでもこれこれと比較してみると
これちょっと結論がおかしくない？あ
そうですか それで終わり
あ そうですか じゃあさらに研究します
結論変えます 訂正します
で 簡単でしょ それは日常生活の中でも
あの人は悪い人に決まってる
あの人は嫉妬深いに決まってるとかね
ああいう決まってる思考を持っちゃうと
思考能力なくなるんです
先入観が入るんです だから
あの人とまあ去年も付き合ってみたし
付き合うたびに嫉妬の話ばっかしでしたと
今年もまあ三回会って
また嫉妬の話ばっかしで
なんか嫉妬深い人のように見えますよと
仮に結論する また その人の性格が変わる可能性
変わってもう嫉妬の話は全く出てこない可能性もあります
そうすると自分が楽です
あ この人の嫉妬がなんかなくなってるみたいという感じで
新しい考えに入ります
思考する方法はそういう方法なんです
結論がし方がないんだけど
保留 なぜならば すべてのデータは私たちには入ってこないのです
自分が達した意見に執着しない
これは気をつけましょう
みんな自分の意見に執着するんです
意見に執着したら 思考能力ないということなんです
だって同じ意見でぐるぐるぐるぐる
主義という言葉がありますね
何々主義とかね 言ったら
あの何々主義だったら思考能力はないんです
思考能力ある人には主義がありません
主義はいくらでも作れます
でも自分には主義がありません
皆見解を持っているが見解は本来偏見であると理解します
例えば皆様 今日は寒いという見解あるかもしれませんね
あれは偏見です 偏見というのは
あの 俗世間での偏見ではなくて
ある見方で見た結論なんです
だから私が自分の体調を持って外に行く
そうすると私の体調という見方でその人の結論になるんです
しかし 元気な若い人は別にっていうことになるんですね
それほど寒くないんだけど
だからその人にはその意見
私には寒いという意見
どちらでも偏見ですね
で 智慧悟っていない人には偏見しか持てないんです
ある見方で見る だからいろんな意見持ってください
構いませんよ 世間に対して
奥さんに対して 旦那さんに対して
子供に対して 友達に対して
いろいろな意見を持ってください
でも すべてこれは偏見であると理解するべき
それで思考能力はどんどん成長していくんです
例えばお母さんがうちの子はとても可愛いよと
それはお母さんの偏見なんです
私の偏見はこういう偏見だと
そうすると他のお母ちゃんがこの子本当に気持ち悪いと言われたって
なるほど その方の偏見なんですね
喧嘩するしようがないんですよ
そうすると思考能力があるんだから
このお母さんに あのね
なんであなたはそう言うんですかね？こいつの何が悪いところあるの？と聞いてみたら
そうすると母に見えないところを何か教えてくれたりする
それは合ってるならば合ってるんであって
合ってないんだったら
それは合ってないってわかればいいんですね
それが思考能力ということなんです
だから私の意見は偏見であると
この偏見とは この間違っておかしいという意味ではないんです
ある見方で見る あるレンズで見ているんですね
それしか我々にはものを見ることはできない
皆様方 明日 例えばカンボジアに行ったりしましょう
行ってレストランに行く
レストランに人間食べるというものは出してますけど
皆様方は日本人だから日本食という角度から見るんだよ
これ仕方がないんです
だからカンボジアの料理は辛すぎとかね
あるいはしょっぱいとかね
なんとか決めるでしょ
それは日本の方の偏見であって
見方であって カンボジア人はそうは思わないんですね
だから安心でしょ 意見は偏見であると覚えておけば
はい 次 思考能力のためにではなくて
智慧のために必要なこと
これ因果関係 全ての現象は因縁によって起きて
因縁によって消えていくのです
全てで それは仏教の真理です
この法則を大事に覚えて
自分の周りの因果関係を発見します
ブッダの説かれた真理だから
一切の現象は因縁によって生じて
因縁によって消えるということはフレーズ覚えておく
それから周りのこと の
あ こういう因縁でこうなっている
こういう原因でこうなっている
こういう原因でこうなった
これからこうなるでしょうというふうに
この因果法則を周りの自分の周りの自分の毎日の経験に当ててみます
朝起きたら機嫌が悪い
すぐ因果法則を当ててみるんです
機嫌が悪い なぜ？あ こういう原因があって
まあ機嫌が悪い じゃあ原因変えれば？で
そうすると機嫌が悪いことは消えるというふうに
因果法則を当ててみるんです
ものすごい思考能力が生まれます
何事でもこうだからこうなったという関係を発見しましょう
こうだからこうなった
これも妄想に行かないように気をつけてください
その場にカットするんです
延々と時間を延ばしていかないんです
こうだからこうなった
だから 10年経ったらこうなるんだよとはやめてください
先入観 好み 大衆の意見
流行 信仰 感情などに乗らない
自分を守ってください
先入観で決めるのをやめてください
好みで決めないでください
これが主観的 大衆の意見
みんなそう思ってるんだから
みんなやってるんだから乗らないでください
みんなってバカですからね
我々は拙者がやっている
みんなじゃないんです
賢者がやって賢者が言っているという狭い範囲で取るんです
だから私は仏教だからブッダが言われた
そこには乗ります ブッダが言われた
アメリカ人が何か反対みたいだからそちらに行くぞ
そんな腰抜け精神はないんです
アメリカ人とロシア人
みんな行ったってもね
ブッダが言ってないならば最悪だから
だから大衆の意見に乗らないんです
大衆が悟ってるわけないでしょう
それから流行 流行って必ずバカのバカな連中が作っているだからね
流行っていつでもよくよく見るとバカどもたちが作るんです
あの知恵の悪い人々はあまり流行を作らないんです
それから信仰 ものすごい毒なんです
信仰は何を信じて何を信じちゃいけないかと全部もう与えてくれるんですね
自分の思考の自由を失っちゃう
宗教の世界は思考能力の反対なんです
思考するなかで信じなさいです
だから聖書にこういう風にあります
信じなさいと コーランにはこういう風にあります
ウパニシャッドではこういう風にあります
信じなさいということになる
これをやめてください
信じる人には思考能力がなくなるんです
感情って何ですかね 時々我々は怒ったり
いろいろね 感情が起きますね
感情の場合は思考能力はなくなるんだから
その時はちょっと待ってください
思考しない 感情があると思考ではなくて妄想になっちゃうんです
子供が何かやっちゃって怒った
怒ったならば 子供に何も喋らないでください
自分の怒りが綺麗に消えちゃって
子供が再び可愛いと感じたところで 「
あのね あんた前こういうことやったでしょ？これは本当は良くないことで
こういう風にやるべきです 」
その後で言ってください
はい 次 私意見を意見にする
人には自分の意見 見解があります
ね 皆様にも私意見があるでしょ
自分の主観では正しいのですが
客観的に普遍的に正しいという保証は一切ありません
これ 我々の人間の罠なんです
私が何か見て 何か聞いて
何か考えて 自分の意見を作る
これは自分にとって正しいんです
だから私はあのお店に行ってラーメンを食べてみて
もう気に入らなくて すごくまずいということになる
だから私はこの店のラーメンはまずいと決めちゃう
これは私の意見 これは私にとって正しいんです
まずいなのに美味しいですよと決めることできません
だからこうするんです
思考能力がある人は 私の意見は私にとって正しいんだけど
これはまあ主観で客観的に正しいっていうことはちょっとわかりませんよと
このお店のラーメンが私にはまずいんだけど
わかりませんよ 必ずまずいラーメンでやってるならば
2日3日で店が潰れますからね
店が何年も続いているっていうことは
美味しいと思っている人々もいるんです
はい このポイントを覚えておけば立派な人間になりますよ
次 意見を述べるとき気をつけましょう
みんなすごいなんか強引に押し付けて喋ってるんですよ
だから会議なんかものすごく気持ち悪い
すごくこの対話して美しくないんです
だから我々はこう喋るべきですよ
私の意見ですが と自分の意見
そうすると柔らかいんです
実はこれ私だけの意見ですけど
そうすると相手の方々は
あ そうということで優しく受け入れるんです
あるいは自分が何か調べて
私はいろいろ調べたんだけど
この私が調べたデータによると
こういう意見になります
あれあれ言ってください
この何て言いますか このレファレンスを
ちゃんと参考 私が調べたところでは
こういうことになっています
私は知らなかったからね
だからこういうことですよ
言っちゃうとまずいんです
それで聞いている人々の中で私が参考にしなかったデータがある
あのね 私はこういうデータもありますけど
とりあえずどうするの？大丈夫ですよ
私が調べたコントロールでこういうこと
あ そのデータ知りませんでしたと
では そのデータを入れて意見を変えますということで立派でしょ
あるいは好みと言っちゃってもいいんです
私の好みはこれで 好みの場合には理由は要りませんね
などの形容詞を使って自我を張ることも
私見を押し付けることも極力避けましょう
それで思考能力はいくらでも上がります
知らないことを知らないという勇気を持つ
これひどいんですよ 世の中知らないということを認めてこないんです
知らないものは知りませんと
言ってください 例えば
先生に生徒が質問する
先生が答えを知らない場合は
すごくプライドが傷ついちゃって
あるいは生徒にくだらないこと聞くなよとかね
余計なこと聞けない 黙って座りなさいとか
なんかヤクザみたいになっちゃうんですね
だったらすいません これって先生知りませんだけどね
答えられませんよ 座ってください
それで子供も落ち着いて座るし
じゃあ授業始まりましょうと
あるいは質問内容を見たら
これは先生も知りませんだから調べましょう
君も調べて私に教えてください
私も自分で調べてみますと
素晴らしい師弟関係あるわけでしょ
だから 知らないことは知らないと言う勇気が
思考能力を持つ人間には欠かせない条件です
次 データの取り方 なんていうのは人から学ばなくちゃいけないでしょ
人間は やっぱり賢者から学びます
賢者といえば唯一はブッダですからね
ブッダと阿羅漢たちは真理を発見したのです
仏法を勉強してみます
そこで思考能力が上がります
あれを口うるさくガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ言ってるのは
仏教から学んだ能力なんです
もうどんな人の意見でもここは間違って
ここは正しいよと言えるのです
科学者にも悪口っていうんですね
科学を全く知らないくせに
だからこの思考能力なんて
それはブッダから学んだものなんです
仏教はどのように命 世界を見ているのかと探求している
だからアインシュタインと違って
オバマさんと違って 次は何人でしたっけ？はい
あ トランプ トランプさんと違ってね
彼らの世間論は役に立たないんです
だから聖者が世界はどのように見ているのかと
例えば政治はどうすればよろしいかと思ったら
ブッダが政治について語ったところあるんです
それを学べば 非常にどんな時代にも適用する政治論があるわけです
例えば経済状況 どうやって仕事をして
どうやってという お釈迦様が教えているのです
こういう風にしなさいと
それは時代を超えての真理になるのです
なぜならば ああいう聖者たちが真理は決しているんです
普遍的な真理 仏教は様々な哲学
見解などを否定しているのです
否定している その理由を学んでみる
それからお釈迦様は批判している教えがあるんです
哲学もあるんです 例えば全知全能の神のこととかね
批判している なんで？すごく頭が良くないです
仏教から見れば 全知全能の神っていうのは成り立たないんです
人間が作った概念以外何でもないんです
それちゃんと教えてます
それはわかりやすい例で
またいろんな見解 例えばヒンドゥー教の儀式儀礼ばかりしています
しかし ヒンドゥー教の人々の道徳的な生き方
それは何も言ってないんです
一部否定して一部認める意見もあります
そういうことで これを学んでみると
私たちにも新しい見方
いわゆる普遍的な見方
偏見ではなく 色眼鏡ではなく
色のない眼鏡が現れる
その眼鏡は倍率ありまして
望遠することもものすごく顕微鏡みたいに倍率を上げることもできます
智慧っていうのは いわゆる全体的に見る能力もあるし
1項目精密に見る能力もあります
その能力を我々育てなくちゃいけないんですね
だから偏見は俗世間に出る限り偏見で仕方がない
ブッダのやり方を学んでみると
偏見がなくなっちゃって
色がついてない調整可能なレンズがついてくるんです
マクロで見たければマクロで見る
マイクロで見たければマイクロで見る
だから私たちはそういう訓練を受けていますよ
問題は マクロで見る場合も
マイクロで見る場合もあります
説法する場合は大体マクロで見て説法する
人と喋る場合はマイクロで
どちらでも真理を言っているのです
だから もう思考能力の人にとっては
このマイクロマクロで見る能力が必要でしょう
次 感情の入れ替え これ悟ってないという想定で喋ってますね
感情があるんですよ 貪瞋痴の感情を慈悲喜捨の気持ちに入れ替える
それで思考できます 貪瞋痴ではろくな思考できません
思考しても副作用があるんです
矛盾になるんです だから感情は入れ替えます
正しい思考ができるようになります
慈悲喜捨になっちゃうと
慈悲喜捨については詳しい説明は今までできませんので
まあ知ってるでしょ 生命を愛する気持ちですよ
ことごとく制限なく 制限なく
差別なく 一切生命を愛する気持ち
その気持ちでいてください
貪瞋痴いらないんです
貪瞋痴はいつでもリミットがあって
節度を超えちゃうと自己破壊します
この この感情に書いてあるんですかね
貪瞋痴の慈悲喜捨の感情に
仏教用語で無量という言葉を使っているんです
いわゆるいくらでも増える
無限 だから今の人間でなくなっちゃいますよ
慈悲喜捨が現れれば すべてマクロで見られます
マイクロで見られます
直ちにその能力がついてきますよ
慈悲喜捨の気持ちを入れ替えることによって
世間の無数の見解の中で正見を見つけられます
だから世間は見解で生きています
気持ち入れ替えちゃうと
見解が正見になるんです
慈悲喜捨の気持ちに無量という形容詞があります
気持ちを入れ替えることで
思考の力が完成するところまで成長します
だから思考能力っていうのは完成するんです
頂点に出すんです やり方
慈悲喜捨で入れ替えるんです
貪瞋痴を慈悲喜捨で入れ替える
慈悲の瞑想はそういうことです
はい 次 我々自我の退場ですね
我々には思考できないのは自由にできないのはね
勉強しても頭が良くならないんですね
覚えられないんですね
すぐ忘れちゃう 仕事をする時でも
あの完いわゆる百パーセント能力を発揮することができない
いつでも中途半端 ぱいぱいで終わっちゃうんですね
満点で生きていられないんですね
仕事をしても満点じゃない
勉強しても満点じゃない
試験を受けても満点じゃない
人生も満点じゃない なんかあるんですね
これは自我という手錠なんです
手錠だけじゃなくて もう一つ足かせも使わなくちゃいけないんです
足にも手にも手錠かけていると
もう動かないでしょ これは自我なんですね
自我で勉強しても 仕事をしても苦しくなります
能力は低下します 一時的でも良いから
勉強するとき 自我を捨ててテーマに客観的に当たる
例えば勉強しなくちゃーという
あの瞬間に自我を忘れてほしい
勉強のテーマに当たるんです
自分を忘れて 仕事をする瞬間で自分を忘れるんです
自分がいないことにするんです
いないことにして仕事に当たるんです
満点で終わります 心の能力はもう笑いもんじゃないんですよ
自我で全部ダメになっているんです
仕事の場合も同じです
行為に集中する 自我は錯覚で
心の力を極力小さくします
自我ってです 幻覚です
この幻覚になっちゃうと
心は仕事をできなくなっちゃって
ものすごい弱くなる だから瞑想修行をしたら自我が消えますけど
錯覚が 我々はやってないんだから
仮にないことにする 勉強するときは自分がないことにして勉強する
仕事をするときは自分がないことにして勉強...仕事をする
料理を作るときでも 自分がないことにして料理に当たるんです
そうすると誰だってプロになるんです
自我を忘れると能力が伸びます
しかし すごい足かせになっています
次はの対話について勉強しましょう
他人との対話 今日は私もまずいことをやっていますけど
自我をなくして相手が理解することに集中する
対話するときでも 自我を消してください
一時的でいいんです あとで我々になってください
今私がいない 私がいないということで相手としゃべるんです
私がいないのに喋っている
喋っている言葉が相手が理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから相手が理解することだけに集中して喋ってほしい
自分が知ってること 自信があることだけ話します
人と喋る場合は 自分がよく知っていることだけ言ってください
これには自信がありますだったら
自分を忘れてこういうこと
こういうことや 例えば先生たちが子供に教える場合も
宿題を教える場合でも
あなたにこれぐらいのことわからないのかと言った途端
アウトですよ 子供に勉強できなくなっちゃうんです
自我がしてるんです 相手を馬鹿にしているんです
自分の自我 だから自我をなくして
このポイント これはこうすればこの子はわかってくれる
自我一時的に消したら
ものすごく喋り方が見えてくるんです
すぐ現れます 簡単です
一方的な話は成り立たない
今日私がやっているような感じでね
これって皆様にとってすごい苦しいんです
一方的に喋ってるから
すべての話は対話であることを理解しましょう
話とは対話である だから
このスライド作っている場合は
私は私と喋っているんです
だからうまくいかないんです
皆様と だから 話す前に原稿を作ったりすることは
自分自身で喋っていることになるんですね
だから原稿を読み上げたっても
聞いている人はもうあくびばっかりで終わっちゃうんですね
早く終わって終わってろとかね
対話だったらそれはないんです
意識しめで語ると たとえ話も例も
言葉の入れ替えも プレゼンテーションの技も自然に現れます
心の慈しみがあれば いくらでもたとえ話が出てくる
言葉を入れ替えることはいくらでもできます
わからなかった じゃあこういう風に言いましょう
いくらでもできます だから自費記者で入れ替えた方がすごい能力が生まれます
はい 話はそれで終了でございます
はい そういうことでなんか時間になってしまいました
では 祈願の御唱でしめいたします
私と一緒に唱えましょう
ドッカパッターチェニンドッカ
バヤンバンターチェニンバヤ
ソーカッバンターチェニッソーカー
ホントゥサンデーピパーニノー
もう一回 ドゥッカンプンターチェニンドゥンカー
バヤンパンターチェニンバヤ
ソーカンパンターチェニッソーカー
ホントゥサンデーピパーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しむなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい どうもありがとうございます